Bob Iger is back in charge of Disney
this is surprising for a couple reasons
the first is Bob chapek has not been in
charge all that long and Bob Iger had
seemed to be enjoying his retirement but
on the other hand this does make sense
for a number of reasons the first is is
that Bob chapek had kind of overseen a
little bit of a rough time there was all
the stuff that went on with the don't
say gay Bill and while that initial
situation was not jpeg's fault he did
not handle it well and there were also
some concerns within Disney structure
with how he had set things up so that
business people had more say over the
creatives and the creatives didn't like
that now it's not to say that didn't
happen at all under Iger or that when
Iger comes in and does the
restructurings he said he's going to do
that there won't be some say over them
but it'll be more weighted in their
favor now there's still issues they're
things that came out actually as a
result of the don't say gay bill that
made it clear even under iger's tenure
there were some issues about that but
this seems to have uh boosted the stock
and gotten people overall more positive
nobody really seemed to like jpeg